what has been a four-year rivalry I
guessed Court dispute battle you could
say this is a very important victory for
Apple is it not yeah Apple really got
some more firepower here and it's
against his rival Samsung obviously just
to give you some perspective back in May
2014 Apple had already won there's 120
million dollar jury verdict against
Samsung but at the time the trial judge
said a monetary damages were enough he
didn't go further and declined an itch
to issue an order where Samson was
forced to remove some of these features
from its smartphone so the features in
question now here is the slide to unlock
the autocorrect as well as the Quick
Links which we are very familiar with so
now that Apple has appealed this ruling
samsung may be forced to change its
products when it comes to those features
and so our Apple has argued before that
they can't really if they can't control
how these patents are going they're
going to lose market share there's going
to lose a reputation as an innovator so
far reaching consequences here some say
that this is a good president alright a
good precedent for set I guess for Apple
but not for samsung and maybe not for
other smartphone makers as well yeah
it's interesting with this case it was
basically apple vs samsung Attell so you
got google HTC LG all backing the korean
smartphone maker and they were saying
that this patent or this decision could
potentially allow patent owners to
leverage their rights for competitive
gain but this decision could be a
powerful tool here the ability to block
the use of an invention you can't
increase the price type for negotiating
settlements app will also reach a
settlement with HTC mind you to include
this no cloning provision on its designs
so this ruling helps to do the same for
other mobile smartphone makers for
example China's shall me of course
trying to enter into the US market
engine